[Aplausos]
[Música]
luxemburgo es el único país del mundo
cuyo primer ministro es abiertamente
homosexual hablamos de una de las
sociedades más abiertas y tolerantes del
planeta de hecho con poco más de 500 mil
habitantes el 40% son inmigrantes
en otras palabras en luxemburgo es el
país más pequeño de la unión europea y a
la vez el que más población inmigrante
tiene sin embargo lo que ha hecho famoso
a este país se resume en una palabra
dinero sí amigos de visual político el
gran ducado de luxemburgo está entre los
tres países más ricos del planeta
aquí el salario mínimo roza los dos mil
euros al mes y eso es el salario mínimo
porque lo normal es cobrar por encima de
los cinco mil euros
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea los
luxemburgueses tienen una renta per
cápita dos veces más alta que la de los
australianos o los daneses pero esperad
un momento porque este número tiene
truco veréis casi la mitad de los
trabajadores de luxemburgo no residen en
este país todos los días alrededor de
160.000 personas cruzan las fronteras
para trabajar y después se vuelven a sus
casas en alemania francia o bélgica
[Música]
es decir que generan riqueza en el país
pero no viven en el mismo por eso cuando
dividimos el pib de luxemburgo entre su
población nos sale una cifra tan alta
pero con o sin desviaciones estadísticas
es innegable que en luxemburgo es algo
así como un país de millonarios y eso
explica que su capital la ciudad de
luxemburgo sea también una de las
ciudades con mayor calidad de vida del
mundo
muchos pensaréis que todo esto se debe a
que el luxemburgo es un paraíso fiscal
pero lo cierto es que otros países como
malta o chipre también atraen a cientos
de empresas con impuestos bajos y no son
ni la mitad de ricos que el luxemburgo
así que la pregunta es qué tiene
luxemburgo para ser tan inmensamente
rico y han hecho en este país para
disfrutar de semejante estilo de vida
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
y además al final del vídeo va a haber
una sorpresa pero antes vamos a ver un
poco de historia
[Música]
los reyes del acero en el año 1815 el
gran ducado de luxemburgo se convierte
en un país independiente y digo
independiente entre comillas porque
ninguno de sus vecinos reconocieron del
todo esta independencia
[Música]
francia y prusia que es lo que hoy en
día conocemos como alemania se pelearon
por el control de este educado en varias
ocasiones es más aunque su gobierno
quisiera ser independiente el territorio
de luxemburgo era propiedad del rey
guillermo tercero de holanda durante
estos años
luxemburgo estaba lejos de ser un país
rico la mayor parte de sus ciudadanos
sobrevivían gracias a la agricultura y
la minería del hierro para que os hagáis
una idea en estas décadas el país perdía
población a marchas forzadas porque 1 de
cada 5 luxemburgueses emigraba a los
eeuu
[Música]
sin embargo tener como vecinos a dos
potencias enfrentadas como eran francia
y prusia también tiene sus ventajas
veréis durante esta época alemania no
existía como país en su lugar había
varias repúblicas reinos educados unidos
bajo una confederación si queréis
entender lo que es una confederación
podéis hacer clic en este otro vídeo lo
cierto es que todos estos estados
alemanes también comerciaban entre ellos
habían creado una especie de área de
libre comercio a la que llamaban el
zollverein
e
[Música]
pues bien en 1842 luxemburgo entró a
formar parte de éste zollverein y desde
entonces la historia no volvió a ser la
misma como os decía antes la paupérrima
economía de luxemburgo se basaba en dos
sectores agricultura y minería del
hierro no olvidéis que estábamos en
plena revolución industrial el acero se
utilizaba para prácticamente todo y a
los luxemburgueses les salía por las
orejas pero no sólo eso hablamos de un
país minúsculo situado en el punto donde
se junta a alemania francia y bélgica
[Música]
en otras palabras que eran el enclave
perfecto para construir un ferrocarril y
enviar mercancías a estos tres países de
repente en luxemburgo se había
convertido en el centro de todas las
rutas comerciales y uno de los mayores
proveedores de hierro y acero del mundo
de hecho muchos de esos rascacielos que
vemos en chicago y nueva york se
construyeron con vigas fabricadas en
este país y eso explica que las empresas
de acero más grandes del mundo sean
luxemburguesas
entre otras la más grande de todas la
que hoy se conoce bajo el nombre de
arcelormittal y que seguro que habéis
visto más de una vez en los periódicos
de economía de hecho de otra forma que
era unas pocas décadas luxemburgo había
pasado de ser un territorio
relativamente pobre a situarse al mismo
nivel que sus vecinos pero todavía
faltaba algo muy importante para que se
convirtiera en el gigante económico que
es hoy en día y ese algo es nada más y
nada menos que
[Música]
1929 ese fue el año en el que luxemburgo
sacó su ley de holdings empresariales y
os preguntaréis qué es un holding
empresarial pues bien vamos a tomar como
ejemplo la cocacola
por un lado cocacola es una marca de
refrescos pero por el otro tenemos a la
coca-cola company inc que es una macro
compañía que engloba a muchas otras
empresas como fanta webs o la propia
cocacola
pues bien esta macro compañía es un
holding y las empresas que lo integran
se llaman filiales
y las filiales pueden estar repartidas
por distintos países y son las
encargadas de producir y distribuir las
bebidas sin embargo la función del
holding es simplemente administrar las
propiedades de estas filiales pues bien
esta ley de 1929 tenía unas condiciones
fiscales fantásticas para los holdings
básicamente pagaban alrededor de un 1%
de impuestos eran los años 30 por aquel
momento la figura del holding no estaba
tan extendida como hoy en día
para que os hagáis una idea por aquella
época actuó acá cola estaba empezando a
expandirse a otros países pero todavía
no era el gigante que es ahora en otras
palabras que luxemburgo crecía así pero
no mucho más que otros países
sin embargo en los años 70 es la época
donde las empresas de eeuu conquistan
los mercados europeos y asiáticos que a
su vez tenían más dinero para consumir
en esta época es cuando surgen muchos de
esos conglomerados empresariales que
conocemos hoy en día es decir que de
repente aparecieron montones de holdings
cuyos beneficios llegan de distintas
partes del mundo y donde se situaban
pues ya han puestos a elegir buscaban un
lugar donde pagar los menos impuestos
posibles luxemburgo ofrecía todo esto y
mucho más para los años 60 y 70 el país
ya contaba con una industria financiera
muy bien especializada los mejores
contables abogados y economistas que
estaban dispuestos a ayudar a estos
grandes empresarios a sacarle el máximo
partido a las leyes luxemburguesas y así
es como este país
en su década de plata
tal cual como lo veis la economía de
luxemburgo se duplicó en menos de seis
años vamos que ríete tú de china o
singapur y habéis oído bien he dicho
década de plata porque todo este
crecimiento fue una tontería comparado
con lo que vino después pensadlo bien
hablamos ya de los años 2000 el boom de
las empresas de internet grandes
gigantes financieros que operan en todo
el mundo
tienen decenas de filiales repartidas
por todo el planeta y no están
circunscritas a ningún territorio
concreto porque hacen ventas en todas
partes en otras palabras que las
empresas tecnológicas eran las más
indicadas para establecerse en
luxemburgo
así que si creíais que un país que ya
era multimillonario no podía crecer
mucho más echarle un vistazo a esta
gráfica
[Música]
por favor si algún día la palabra a
nacho vidal ya no aparece en el
diccionario de la rae quiero que
utilicen esta gráfica como ilustración
no sé si os habéis fijado pero en sólo
cinco años
luxemburgo pasó de tener una renta per
cápita de 50 mil dólares que ya es
bastante a superar los 100 mil dólares
cuando vives en un país con una renta
per cápita de 100 mil dólares haces el
calimocho con vega sicilia para que os
hagáis una idea el audi a3 es el tercer
coche más vendido en luxemburgo
[Música]
y ya sé lo que estáis pensando que este
país se ha hecho rico gracias a la
evasión de impuestos verdad pues la
respuesta es mucho más compleja que todo
esto veréis el hecho de que un holding
corporativo esté ubicado en luxemburgo
no significa que sus filiales no tengan
que pagar impuestos en otros países al
menos en teoría
por ejemplo el holding de amazon tiene
su sede en luxemburgo sin embargo su
filial española es decir la empresa que
se encarga de vender los productos y
gestionar los envíos en este país tiene
que tributar en españa bueno al menos en
teoría en la práctica en la práctica es
un poquito distinto los clics volvamos
al ejemplo de amazon como decíamos los
beneficios que gane su filial española
tienen que tributar en españa verdad
pero y si no tuvieran beneficios imagina
que justo antes de ir a pagar los
impuestos
amazon españa pide un préstamo enorme
y préstamo con un tipo de interés
altísimo tanto que deja temblando su
cuenta de resultados y os preguntaréis
quien les presta este dinero
efectivamente el holding que tiene
amazon en luxemburgo de esta forma las
filiales de esta empresa apenas tienen
que declarar beneficios de una forma u
otra casi todo ese dinero termina en la
cuenta luxemburguesa que como hemos
dicho antes a unos impuestos mucho más
bajos por supuesto que todo esto es
legal pero en el año 2009 en mitad de la
gran crisis financiera el gobierno de
eeuu se dio cuenta de la cantidad de
dinero que estaba perdiendo con todas
estas grandes empresas por eso hoy voy a
anunciar un paquete de propuestas para
luchar contra la evasión ilegal de
impuestos fuera del país cerrar los
vacíos legales y hacer más rentable que
las empresas creen trabajos aquí en eeuu
a partir de aquí el resto de gobiernos
siguieron
ejemplo de obama no olvidéis que
luxemburgo es uno de los miembros
fundadores de la unión europea
eso significa que sus compañeros de club
podrían hacer aún más presión política
pero sin duda alguna la verdadera crisis
en este país llegó en el año 2014
en este momento es cuando un grupo de
contables publicaron miles de datos
privados de todas estas grandes
compañías gracias al llamado lux leaks
todos hemos podido ver las estrategias
de evasión fiscal que habían puesto en
práctica
miles de corporaciones recordáis lo que
os he contado de los préstamos entre
distintas filiales de un mismo holding
pues todavía podemos mejorar aún más
este esquema
[Música]
veréis todas estas grandes empresas
contratan a grandes consultoras para que
les lleven la contabilidad consultoras
como por ejemplo price waterhouse
coopers que tienen una enorme cantidad
de clientes en luxemburgo tantos
clientes como para poder sentarse a
negociar directamente con el primer
ministro del país que por entonces era
jean-claude juncker
juncker en el punto de mira tras las
revelaciones de evasión fiscal en
luxemburgo los documentos filtrados
demostrarían acuerdos fiscales
negociados por pricewaterhousecoopers
como os podéis imaginar la publicación
de estos looks leaks ha cambiado
totalmente las reglas del juego de hecho
en el año 2017
luxemburgo ya ha sacado una nueva
reforma fiscal y probablemente muchos de
estos acuerdos preferenciales con
grandes compañías pasen a ser historia
pero esperad un momento porque esto no
significa el fin de la prosperidad
luxemburguesa más bien todo lo contrario
es más pese a todas estas turbulencias
políticas este país creció el año pasado
a un ritmo del 4 2% mucho más rápido que
españa o que prácticamente cualquier
otro país europeo
[Música]
teniendo tantísimo dinero ahorrado los
luxemburgueses han podido invertir en
muchos otros sectores
hablamos de industrias como el acero los
bancos o el espacio exterior
[Música]
una apuesta de luxemburgo por la
industria especial muestra señales de
éxito temprano tal cual como lo hice de
hecho luxemburgo y eeuu han sido los dos
primeros países en sacar leyes para
regular la minería en el espacio
exterior
[Música]
y en esta pequeña nación esperan
convertirse en el silicon valley del
espacio y eso también explica en parte
esta nueva reforma fiscal que han sacado
en este año 2017 por supuesto el
gobierno de luxemburgo ya no quiere
ayudar a las grandes corporaciones a
evadir impuestos al menos eso es lo que
dicen oficialmente en su lugar han
reducido los impuestos para las empresas
pequeñas
es decir que quieren mejorar las
condiciones para que puedan surgir
nuevas startups tecnológicas pero de eso
hablaremos en un próximo vídeo
[Música]
así que ahora la pregunta es volveremos
a ver un crecimiento vertiginoso de la
economía de luxemburgo veremos algún día
cómo este país se convierte en el líder
mundial de la industria aeroespacial
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y ahora llega la sorpresa os
acordáis de nuestros amigos de china and
sensor pues nos han escrito para
pedirnos que hagamos un challenge de
esos que se hacen en youtube como sabéis
al gobierno chino no le gusta la
disidencia política y tienen una
especial fijación con los practicantes
de falun gong que es un tipo de
meditación trascendental cada año miles
de personas son capturadas o asesinadas
por esta razón especialmente las mujeres
[Música]
y para que todos estemos concienciados
con esta causa
anastasia link que es una activista y
modelo ha sacado este reto el hashtag
locus challenge la idea es que ahora
tengo que grabar me haciendo yoga
durante 5 segundos y yo creo que son 5
segundos porque como fueran 5 minutos
habría que llamar a una ambulancia así
que allá voy
lo tienes bien lo tienes por ahí vamos a
ver
esto es la primera vez que me pongo a
hacer una cosa de estas
a ver me he visto un tutorial en youtube
sobre cómo hacer la posición del loto
así que por aquí va un pie
por aquí va el otro
vamos a ver 1 2 y 3
la madre que parió al chapela nastassja
line está
bien
bueno pues como os decía si queréis
conocer otra historia de éxito de 'el
que es el primer país más rico del mundo
en este otro vídeo descubriréis la
historia de qatar haced clic aquí para
verlo y no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros al canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]